kryptisch wird nach wie vor in meinem
kopf herum ich komme nicht davon los und
wie es der zufall so will haben wir
diese woche mal wieder eine menge glück
und kommt nur in kranken die machen
bleibt bis zum ende dran denn ist nichts
so wie es scheint und vergesst nicht das
video zu leiten wenn es euch gefällt
viel spaß mit dieser folge von rolex
ich bin gerade mit leo eigentlich wegen
dem ganz anderen video hier in der stadt
aber hier im schaufenster steht mit 30
70 wenn es die wirklich gibt kaufe ich
die für rolex trade ab sofort ich kenne
das wäre das wären freely paar hundert
euro
ok warum bin ich hier gerade so
aufgeregt und freue mich darüber eine
normale grafikkarte im schaufenster zu
sehen durch den klub deshalb in den
letzten monaten ist es quasi unmöglich
geworden eine leistungsstarke
grafikkarte die normalen preis zu
bekommen jede rtx 30 70 30 80 oder 30 90
wird deutlich über dem normalen preis
gehandelt und als normaler verbraucher
zocker streamer oder jemand der videos
produziert guckt man momentan absolut in
die röhre
da diese grafikkarten zum einen von
cryptic genutzt werden sind die preise
absolut durch die decke gegangen und
dadurch auch eine riesen chance für
unser trader bevor ich euch aber zeige
was daraus geworden ist ob wir sie
bekommen konnten und ob er damit profit
machen konnten schauen wir uns erstmal
die krypto hebel trades aus dem letzten
video wobei ich erwarte schreckliches
vielleicht könnt ihr euch daran erinnern
dass wir adam bitcoin und e terium in
einem der letzten videos gehebelt haben
und die position noch nicht aufgelöst
haben die laufen noch und vielleicht
habt ihr mitbekommen dass in den letzten
tagen doch in der relativ negative
richtung mit den ganzen crypto währungen
liegen ich habe keine ahnung was uns
erwartet wir schauen rein und gucken wie
viel gewinn oder verlust wir machen
konnten verlust machen konnten perfekt
ich habe im letzten video in den
kommentaren super großkotzig geschrieben
dass ich kein stop loss brauche ich hab
kein stop loss reingetan wenn wir pops
genommen wurden dann richtig 321 okay
unsere terium position läuft noch sieht
aber schrecklich aus wir konnten unsere
position mit unserer limit sell order
tatsächlich mit profit verkaufen mit
ordentlich profit unsere bitcoin
position wurde leider liquidiert wir
haben unser komplettes geld das wir ein
bitcoin gesteckt hatten verloren das war
zum glück unsere kleinste position die
circa 300 dollar wäre noch nicht da war
größer das hat super funktioniert und
unsere terium position läuft weiterhin
und da sind wir gerade zehn prozent
insgesamt stehen wir gerade bei 900 und
3 euro und 59 cent
das bedeutet wir sind 100 euro unter dem
geld mit dem er eingestiegen sind nicht
perfekt aber es könnte deutlich
schlimmer sein
dem klub markt geht so schlecht dafür
geht unserem portfolio eigentlich noch
ganz gut die große frage ist jetzt
allerdings nur was machen wir mit dem
geld das wir jetzt gerade wieder zur
verfügung haben kaufen demnach an diesem
eigentlich sehr günstigen einstieg mich
interessiert aber was würdet ihr machen
in den kommentaren wurde immer viel
geschrieben ich hätte das komplett
anders gemacht ich hätte hätte das so
und so gemacht bitte schreib mir also in
die kommentare was ich mit dem
verbleibenden 500 offenen dollar auf
meinem account machen soll und dann
halte ich mich an die kommentare werde
damit das geld investieren unsere
stimmung schon mal auf ein video ein
dass in den nächsten wochen kommt wo ich
meinen touch pad mit 1000 euro crypto
hauptrennen lassen habt ihr im
schaufenster so eine 30 70 stehen so
eine grafikkarte ja wenn ihr die da
jetzt würde ich sie sofort mitnehmen
die so weit ist das hier sehen kann
trotz die grafikkarte 1500 euro im ries
wenn das klappt das wäre komplett denk
ich kann nicht einschätzen wie 2008 eur
das wären instant 500 euro instant und
es tut mir leid für alle gamer weil ich
weiß wie ihr rave nach irgendeiner art
von grafikkarten dem ist halt einfach
zur richtigen zeit am richtigen ort
ja gut aber dann würde ich dir wohl
mitnehmen hahaha letzter zu werden
wieder die augen vielen vielen dank
schönen tag
[Musik]
dann erzähle ich habe eine 30 70 und
eine maus zusammen für 1800 gekauft die
einfach im schaufenster stand das ist
unglaublich entweder ich kaufe die aus
dem projekt raus und wir bauen uns den
lang ersehnten schritt recht den wir
unendlich doll brauchen den wir nicht
zusammen bauen konnten weil keine
grafikkarten da man bei stock x1000 500
euro für uns unbezahlbar weil wir dem
rechner brauchen hallo du geil
doch werden wir haben die gekauft 500
direkt zack zack und die maus kostenlos
dazu da es komplett gestört ich war noch
so zu den tag kommen später doch ja die
sehen nicht da ist einfach wir sind
wieder zu hause ich kann es immer noch
kaum glauben bekommt in diesem auskommen
natürlich hatten wir die möglichkeit
eine asus geforce gtx 30 70 zu kaufen
für 1000 8 mit dieser mode zusammen
die haben wir quasi kostenlos mit dazu
gekommen jetzt schauen wir mal genau wie
viel wert ist wie viel die gehandelt
wird und wie viele leute bereit sind
dafür zu zahlen
du musst wissen wir suchen schon sehr
lange für uns persönlich neue
grafikkarten weil wir selber darauf
angewiesen sind genug power beim
schneiden und auch irgendwie zum zocken
und stream zu haben und man kommt gerade
einfach man kommt gerade einfach nicht
dran ist hat mich so geschockt als ich
vorbei gelaufen bin und ich dachte es
wäre einfach nur um die leute in den
laden zu locken und sie war gar nicht da
wichtig dass wir nachgefragt haben und
dass wir die erstehen kommen 1600
30 dollar das ist ganz ganz krank wir
sehen hier den preisverlauf die wurden
4500 1400 irgendwo so um den dreh
verkauft gerade liegen wir bei 1500
dollar ungefähr das ist unfassbar und
das bedeutet dass wir 400 euro safe
gewinn gemacht haben jetzt gucken wir
mal noch was die maus wert ist mit dem
haus kostet tatsächlich auch 50 euro auf
ebay findet man eine für 35 stellen die
beiden sachen und ein und probieren
natürlich möglichst viel herauszuholen
obwohl ich sagen muss dass ich schon mit
dem gedanken spiele die es verkaufen
weil günstiger kommen wir nicht ran also
haben wir wie immer möglich gute bilder
gemacht bilder verkaufen
hallo ich sehe hier gerade ein kleines
problemchen tatsächlich sind die überall
auf ebay schon für 1300 zu finden wären
dann im endeffekt nur 300 350 euro
gewinnen mit der maus ich dachte das
wäre deutlich mehr
die grafikkarte zu verkaufen ist aber
natürlich nicht die einzige option um
profit daraus zu schlagen es gäbe
natürlich auch die möglichkeit zu meinen
wir haben uns also direkt angesetzt und
gruppen die profitable das meer und das
ist dabei rumgekommen ist echt mega
krass drei dollar 35 cent profit am tage
bei unserem stromkosten bringt überhaupt
nichts können wir komplett in die tonne
kloppen
scheiße deswegen sind die auch nicht so
viel wert naja nichtsdestotrotz ich
stelle jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
profit machen wir damit auf jeden fall
für einen halben tag arbeit in dem wie
in der stadt unterwegs waren nehmen wir
diese 100 200 oder 300 euro profit auf
jeden fall mit beide anzeigen bei ebay
online jetzt stellen wir die noch einmal
schnell bei stalking ein problem ist nur
wir müssen uns eigentlich vorher
entscheiden ob wir die rauskaufen oder
nicht wir könnten sie sehr gut
gebrauchen der waren lange zeit nicht
bereich die resale preise zu zahlen und
sich jetzt da einzureihen und eine
grafikkarte im retail zu kaufen und sie
dann für mehr geld zu verkaufen
finde ich ein bisschen schwierig wenn
wir die grafikkarte für 1300 euro bei
stock picks verkaufen bleiben nur 137
euro und 50 cent nach gebühren übrig
deswegen kommt das für mich eigentlich
nicht infrage ich warte jetzt darauf ob
jemand bei kleinanzeigen für 1300 euro
nimmt und das wäre nach all den tagen
jetzt sieben tage später haben uns dafür
entschieden die grafikkarte zu behalten
wir haben die ganze zeit danach gesucht
jetzt haben wir einmal die chance haben
die einmal da liegen jetzt wollen wir
die nicht weg geben wollen darauf selber
im schnitt rechner bauen
ich finde das deutlich sympathischer die
jetzt nicht auch noch von lisa krise zu
profitieren
wir hatten leute die bereit wären 1280
euro oder 1270 euro dafür zu bezahlen
deswegen versuchen wir die ich kaufe die
aus dem projekt raus und bebauen eigenen
rechner daraus erst ein link in der
video beschreibung findet ihrem 1 2
kanal werden wir in den nächsten tagen
in den nächsten wochen irgendwann
rechner zusammen basteln die maus
konnten wir für 35 euro verkaufen also
ist alles bestens wir konnten profit
machen auch wenn ich den aus meiner
eigenen tasche gegeben habe wir haben
aber nicht weiter zu der krise
beigetragen wir haben jetzt eine
grafikkarte wir können rechner bauen
und trotzdem haben wir das glück genutzt
und die grafikkarte direkt aus dem
schaufenster mit genug ja es war wieder
glück dass mit diesem video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen wenn ihr alle gerne
leica vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren damit die kleinste folgenden
videos verpasst wir sehen uns kommenden
sonntag macht's gut